can't wait to go to another concert mike
let me get out finally get out of town
hang out
you know go go see your favorite band
perform i know you're a big switch foot
guy
go watch them perform um
don't want to miss the next avenged
sevenfold concert
i could do without those all right well
a five-finger death punch
could be performing ah what do i look
like a [ __ ] e3
walking around like i need like i need
five finger death punch to [ __ ]
pander to me and call me a hero
[ __ ] outta here drink some ribbons i'm
on the wrong side of heaven
[ __ ] the worst band ever they're so
bad
he every e3 with a beard that's the
[ __ ] the kill switch dude
somebody asked is the ticket master
thing real this is from uh cbs los
angeles this is real ticketmaster to
verify covet vaccination status of fans
before issuing concert passes
an experimental vaccine for covet 19
continues to make progress
the concert industry is prepping for
potential return to live events in the
coming months
ticketmaster is working on a plan to use
smartphones
to verify whether customers have been
vaccinated or tested for coronavirus
according to billboard
while the plan is still not early phases
billboard reports that the process
would involve fans using the
ticketmaster app in partnership with
medical information firms in vaccines
and testing distributors
upon buying a ticket fans
would be required to either verify their
vaccination status
or prove they have tested negative for
coronavirus within 72 hours prior to
concert dates
regional health authorities would
determine the length of coverage of any
test
after being tested customers would
authorize a lab to share the results
with the health pass
company such as ibm
or clear um now
i maybe i'm wrong but clear i believe
are the same
people that do when you go to the
airport you know like the you could
bypass the security if you sign to the
facial recognition thing
i think it might be the same company how
about this though right and this is just
a thought right
what if i lie well to them
you can't the way that that's the thing
though you can't why they're not the law
it's i'm not saying you lie or don't lie
when you buy your this is how it's gonna
work okay when you buy your ticket your
tickets on your phone
before they when they scan your ticket
to let you go in you have to go get
either
a vaccine or you have to go get a
negative test within 72 hours
at one of their people that work with
them
and they will then in the in their
computer
you have to give them the right because
a hipaa law say yes i allow you to give
this information a ticket master
then the third party which are doctors
or whatever whoever's doing it
has to say yes it's a negative it's a
negative uh
you know uh coronavirus test or
yes they got the vaccine that's wow
because i was going to say what if what
if this is like one of those things
where they go uh
like when you're trying to get a certain
kind of paperwork or whatever and they
go like
we need proof of residency and you just
like photoshop
a utility bill you can't do that you
can't do that old gag
that's because that was that was my
whole approach would be like i would
just get
fake paperwork that says that i'm
vaccinated
so it continues um it says
any fan who tests positive or failed to
verify vaccination status would be
denied access to the event
ucla school of public health professor
ann romano
says that the idea may sound good but
there are many more complex issues
associated with large gatherings at this
time
the test you have today doesn't mean you
can't be exposed and they become
infected
after the time she said romano added the
false negatives and other malfunctions
can give a false sense of security and
make people feel safer than they
actually are
i miss it too but i really implore
people to just because you could do
something doesn't mean you should
she said by the way jim inward has a
good point it sounds like it's more
secure than voting
while some details are still murky the
reports say ticketmaster would only
receive verification of customer status
and would not store or have access to
medical records
uh-huh all data shared would be required
to be in compliance with the medical
privacy laws
sure i'm so glad i'm finally now
like i i i just maybe it's just because
of my age like i'm not
i don't really care to go to any of
these things anyway
like sporting events might be annoying
and stuff but like
i'm not going to be going to a lot of
loud concerts and music festivals but
this this still
is like bizarre but hey royce
i have to i have to make this one point
it's a private company bro
it's a private company dude they can do
whatever they want it's a private
company
the the level of [ __ ] stupidity that
is associated with this
but maybe this will maybe this will lead
to less people doing [ __ ] with
ticketmaster though
if it really hurts the ticket sales i
would love that i would love for people
to do less [ __ ] with ticketmaster the
problem is is that
every time a new ticketing online
ticketing company comes by ticketmaster
buys them
like event live they bought them like
every time a new one comes out they
bought them
and see the problem is is that also i
guess what this means is is that
can you not like back in the day if you
don't want to pay the whatever like 30
to ticket processing for ticketmaster
you could actually go at 10 a.m to the
box office
and just buy the ticket at the box
office can you not do that anymore
like you know what i mean like
ticketmaster was supposed to be an
alternative where people didn't want to
go to the box office and actually buy a
ticket it's just you know i'm gonna just
buy it online whatever i'll just
pay it to be easier so i have to [ __ ]
stand in line to see i don't know
[ __ ] the eagles or whatever and now
it's
the they're going to give every concert
is going to give their business a
ticketmaster i think that's going to
make ticketmaster even
bigger um honestly because they're not
going to want to have to deal with it
um by the way shakespeare and it's worth
it for the safety i hope you're kidding
i hope that's it
i'm sure i'm sure he's joking because
that's a i mean
if the if the alternative is like oh no
we might be unsafe
let's have the government force needles
into us then i'm not
i don't want to be safe like the world
is becoming
less and less of a place i want to be
anyway at this point so
like they're not it's not like you know
these people in charge
have much of a have much leverage at
this point
you don't really have much of a
bargaining chip what is the bargaining
chip if i don't get this vaccine
i can't participate on this in this
world that i
honestly am not even 100 sure i want to
be a part of anymore
hey uh like royce was jokingly saying at
the beginning of this thing
hey if you don't get your vaccine you
can't go to the five finger death punch
concert
oh gee what am i gonna do i don't know
literally anything else
like i don't want to be around these
people anymore i don't want to be
around these people and around these
events i don't like these people anymore
so what are you keeping from me what are
you keeping me from
i barely want to leave my house anymore
i hate most people